all right senator Mitch McConnell and
Chuck Schumer debating on the Senate
floor at the Senate Majority Leader
unveils his plans for Phase three of the
coronavirus relief so what can we expect
in this agreement what has to be in
what's still up for debate here to
discuss it the chairman of the Senate
Republican Conference Senator John
Barrasso senator thanks for joining us
senator Mitch McConnell came up with a
plan and then the Democrats came up with
a plan now it's time to get together he
doesn't want to stick with for
leadership he wants two dozen and some
on the left are saying we're not gonna
get anything done with the group that
size how do you feel well this is a
rescue operation for our country we need
immediate relief for people all across
America to me that's direct support as
well as dealing with the medical
component of this I think we need all
hands on deck the more senators involved
in discussing it the better we have a
number of task forces who are working on
it we're working straight through the
weekend we need to go big we need to be
bold on this and it needs to be
bipartisan Brian we have two crises
right now we have the health care crisis
and the economic crisis and until we get
this medical crisis behind us we're not
going to be able to do what we need to
do to recover our economy so you're
getting some pushback already up to
$1,200 per individual 24 hours for 2,400
hours per couple that would be for a
couple that makes I believe under
$175,000 in the seventy-five thousand
dollar threshold and a 500 hour payment
per child is all these things stealin
still being battered about that's all
part of the discussion we know we have
people all across the country in every
community from the places in Wyoming all
the way to New York City in California
who through no fault of their own are
out of work businesses have had to shut
down so we have to focus on the people
the families as well as the businesses
because we want those businesses to
continue to be viable so the folks when
this pandemic passes can have those jobs
that the jobs will be there but they
need immediate relief and direct support
now now I hear you but how to do it and
who gets it the airlines they need 50
billion to survive there's pushback from
the Democrats saying we're not going to
give it to these big corporation
we got to give it to the people casinos
they need money restaurant tourists
small business need money and here's a
statement from the Schumer Pelosi
leadership group we're beginning to
review senator McConnell's proposal and
on first reading it is not at all
pro-worker and instead puts corporations
way ahead of workers your response well
I want everybody to review it in the
standpoint of the corporations the goal
there is loans only not direct support
but for small businesses and the folks
who work for them it would be direct
support so they can continue to make
their payroll so they continue to keep
the doors basically ready to be reopened
by paying the rent and the electric
bills those sorts of things so we need
to make sure that all of America is
ready to be brought back to life
economically once the disease is
defeated just how you do that and how
you gonna get done and if time is the
essence it seems like boats are on the
other side when do you think we can
expect a bill well the goal is to have
something ready by Monday we're gonna
work all day today tomorrow Sunday I've
already met with a couple of senators
earlier this morning this is going to be
an all-hands-on-deck effort to try to
get this done and get it to the House of
Representatives Monday is the goal the
American people expect us to act and do
it in a bipartisan way you know Brian
things you're usually pretty slow up
here we passed that first to medical
relief bill that got signed earlier this
week a hundred billion dollar bill to
help additionally and now this is the
third part of what will likely be more
to come as we go to recover the economy
after the medical component is behind us
and lastly real quick senator Feinstein
senator Loffler and senator Burr been
accused of dumping a whole bunch of
stock right before the stock market
bailed out what's your reaction to that
I've seen the report I don't know the
details I know we'll hear more but look
we all know the rules when we all know
the laws and we are expected to live by
them that's what our constituents expect
that's what we expect of one another and
I expect to hear from each of them later
today
and just please don't let these
corporations buy their own stock with
the money that we give them even if
our loans Center Brasa they got to play
this this game straight absolutely it's
absolutely right this is we're all in we
need to all be in this together it is a
rescue operation for America which means
medical treatment immediate relief and
then recovery as soon as we can get the
medical problem solved absolutely and
your doctor as well as the senator thank
you so much senator thank you Brian